well you go get flak for what anything
oh if you're in the media you're going
to get flak from for almost anything you
do from all sides so you know in the
early days of MTV if you started talking
about some of these issues people can
come on you know come on man play the
music you know we're not that interested
or people would say you know on one hand
you're promulgating certain stereotypes
and then on another hand you're trying
to level them and break through them but
you're you're part of the problem as you
are you're more a part of the problem
and you might think some people would
say why are you getting young people we
actually had this happen why are you
looking to get young people involved
more involved in the political process
they're really not if they don't want to
vote and participate it's because
they're not interested and they're not
interested because they don't really
know and they don't really care so why
do we want a lot of uninformed LLL
inform people participating in schooling
the results of any election you actually
get thoughts along those lines as well
you know you were you wouldn't be
necessarily responding to every
particular complaint someone might have
about you but I think one of the you
know your most basic response to any of
those things with look we're this is an
issue in our society you know we were
trying to educate people as to what's
going on and raise their awareness and
hopefully their participation and we
think that that's a good thing we don't
know necessarily these people are going
to be liberal or conservative or what
kind of party they're going to belong to
but just being a functioning member of
the democracy is a good thing so if you
get a problem with that so be it
you